when it comes to planets in our solar
system's habitable zone one world is too
close to the sun
another is too far and earth is just
right
but maybe things would be different if
venus and mars simply swapped orbits
what makes these planets impossible to
live on right now
[Music]
what changes would they undergo when
they traded places
and why would you need jupiter to give
these planets a chance at supporting
life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if venus and mars swapped orbits
our solar system's habitable zone
otherwise known as the goldilocks zone
is the distance from a star where liquid
water could exist on the surface of a
planet
as long as conditions aren't too hot or
too cold life could be possible just
like on earth
but simply occupying prime real estate
in the habitable zone isn't a guarantee
that a rocky planet is actually
habitable
both venus and mars orbit within this
region too and yet
no life
despite being of a similar size and with
roughly the same surface gravity as
earth venus is too hot to hold liquid
water
and dense
its atmosphere is 90 times denser than
our own and the surface temperature is a
scorching
462 degrees celsius
on the other end of the goldilocks zone
mars is also quite earth-like
except way colder drier and dustier
its average surface temperature is minus
46 degrees celsius and it has an
atmosphere about one percent as thick as
earth's
so if we swap things around
would venus and mars transform
themselves into perfectly livable
planets
hey all i need to make my planet livable
is a decent grill and some omaha steaks
hey and as father's day is approaching
let me give you some advice on what dad
wants it's steaks and right now you can
give him this mouth-watering gift for
just 99
it's a limited time package that
includes 16 of their tastiest entrees
i'm talking tender smoky bacon wrapped
filet mignon gourmet jumbo franks and
air chilled boneless chicken breasts and
to top it all off delicious caramel
apple tartlets
hungry yet well stop buying the same
lame ties for dad and give them the
experience they've been craving get this
deal now visit
omahastakes.com and type what if in the
search bar to order the dad's want
steaks package order now and get eight
of their new bigger omaha steaks burgers
absolutely free and remember everything
is backed by their 100 money back
guarantee
now if you'll excuse me i like my steaks
like i like this new mars
just a little red
bringing the red planet into venus's
orbit would put it at a distance of
approximately
108 million kilometers from the sun
this would bring it halfway closer to
the sun than it was before
being so much closer mars would get a
significant boost in the amount of
sunlight it receives and that alone can
make the surface temperature climb to a
balmy 32 degrees celsius
just like the earth's tropics
but without a thick atmosphere or oceans
all this new heat wouldn't stay on the
planet
just like in earth's deserts mars would
see extreme temperature differences
between day and night
the thin martian atmosphere would make
it difficult for water to stay liquid
with such a low surface pressure water
would boil at a lower temperature
evaporation would happen much quicker
looks like if you want to see life
flourish on mars you'd have to take a
slightly more hands-on approach
but first let's check out how venus is
doing in its new neck of the woods
you'd now find venus located
228 million kilometers away from the sun
that's twice as far as it used to be
and naturally you'd think surely this
scorching planet would be starting to
cool down
well as it turns out the planet's high
surface temperatures have a lot more to
do with its thick atmosphere than its
overall closeness to the sun
venus has a very high albedo which means
that it reflects about 75 percent of the
incoming sunlight
so it could be that the planet's
temperature remains more or less just as
hot as before
even as the upper parts of the
atmosphere slowly cool enough for the
albedo effect to decrease
that would mean that venus could now
absorb a larger amount of incoming
sunlight so that temperature wouldn't
start to drop all that much
another setback on the road to becoming
a life-supporting planet would be that
venus's atmosphere is mostly comprised
of carbon dioxide with small amounts of
nitrogen and clouds of sulfuric acid
what you still wouldn't find nearly
enough of is water
the concentration of water in venus
atmosphere is 100 times too low for even
the most resilient organisms back on
earth to survive
but since you went through all the
effort of bringing both planets from one
end of the habitable zone to the other
why not take things a little further
you could try terraforming the planets
to make them a little more livable
one way you could increase the surface
pressure of mars would be to try
releasing all the carbon dioxide found
in its soil and minerals
the only problem here is that the red
planet would need to reach temperatures
above 300 degrees celsius
and despite this new location so close
to the sun
mars would never get this hot
besides if you could release all of that
precious greenhouse gas it would only
amount to an atmospheric pressure of
about 10 to 14 percent of earth's
there simply isn't enough carbon dioxide
on the red planet
even if you had been successful with
that effort you'd still be unable to
breathe on mars one option for dealing
with this would involve bringing special
microorganisms to the planet that could
convert the hostile martian atmosphere
into breathable air
this would be similar to what earth was
like two and a half billion years ago
back then
cyanobacteria converted our methane and
ammonia-rich atmosphere into the
oxygen-rich one you enjoy today
but ultimately this would be a big waste
of time and resources
you'd find that with mars's weak
magnetic field it wouldn't be able to
hold on to any atmosphere you could
create
that would be thanks to the power of
solar winds that would constantly strip
away
whatever atmosphere you'd manage to
generate
and sitting in venus's old orbit solar
winds would be almost five times as
dense as mars is used to
way out on venus the question of
creating conditions for life could come
down to whether you could manage to form
an ocean on the planet and that would
entail bombarding the atmosphere with
hydrogen
as hydrogen is introduced to the
atmosphere it would react with the
carbon dioxide leading to the formation
of water
introduce enough hydrogen and you could
eventually see venus with eighty percent
of its surface covered in water
for this to work you'd need a lot of
hydrogen
so much that you'd probably need to find
a way to harvest it from a gas giant
like jupiter or saturn or maybe one of
their moons
yeah i'm not sure all this planet moving
and hydrogen bombarding was really worth
it
you'd still be left with only one
goldilocks planet capable of supporting
life
but
what if
all the planets were in the habitable
zone
[Music]
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]